[Music]
in order to become a butterfly a
caterpillars body dissolves almost
completely and is rebuilt from its own
juices as inconvenient and even
downright dangerous as this process
sounds it's actually quite common
butterflies are just a few of the
800,000 insect species that transition
from largely to adults through complete
metamorphosis that's approximately 85%
of insects and 70% of all known animal
species but how exactly does a
caterpillar become a butterfly when a
caterpillar hatches from an egg it has
none of a butterfly's physical traits it
does have groups of cells inside its
body called imaginal discs that will
eventually become its butterfly parts
for now these cells remain dormant
juvenile hormone suppresses their
activity and prevents the caterpillar
from beginning metamorphosis to early
immediately after hatching the
caterpillar begins to feed building up
fat until it's rigid skin called a
cuticle becomes too tight at this point
a hormone called ectis own triggers the
cuticle to shed or molt as the
caterpillar grows it usually malts four
times then when it's nice and plump the
caterpillars levels of juvenile hormone
drop which triggers it to stop eating
and moving a final burst of Ekta sown
prompts the caterpillars cells to begin
to self-destruct
soon the muscles fat and other tissues
are almost entirely liquefied though the
imaginal discs stay intact and begin to
grow at the same time a second skin
layer called the pupil cuticle forms
underneath the first one more molt
exposes the hard exterior of the pupa
besides the imaginal discs only a few
tissues are spared including
parts of the respiratory system the
heart some abdominal muscles and the
mushroom bodies of the brain the
caterpillar juice then fuels the
development of the imaginal discs in two
eyes and ten eye legs wings genitalia
and other body parts once its new body
is built the insect molds one last time
shedding the pupil cuticle from there
it's free to fly away a new butterfly
even after such a dramatic
transformation the butterfly does retain
some memories from its caterpillar days
it's likely the mushroom bodies of the
brain carry important knowledge from the
caterpillar over to the adult butterfly
how did such an involved developmental
process come to be we don't know for
sure the leading theory is that the
caterpillar is actually a drawn out
version of a life stage that takes place
inside the egg for some other insects
according to this hypothesis over
millions of years the larvae evolved the
ability to eat and live outside the egg
regardless of how complete metamorphosis
originated it's become part of the life
cycles of a dizzying number of insect
species still plenty of species get
along perfectly well with a simpler
developmental process what survival
advantages might complete metamorphosis
provide to make up for the added hassle
for one it keeps larvae and adults from
competing for the same habitats and food
sources and while the pupae may seem
vulnerable this immobile stage can
actually be a good way to pass parts of
the year when food is scarce to us a
butterfly's metamorphosis might sound as
fantastic as a phoenix rising from its
ashes but these transformations are
taking place all around us all the time
from the Hercules beetle to the honeybee
to the garden ant countless squishy
larvae dissolve and emerge as armoured
aerodynamic and nimble adults
[Music]
this video was animated by one of our
all-time favorite artists avi / avi has
been animating ted-ed lessons since 2012
and this is actually his 20th video on
our platform if you want to see more of
Abhi's clever and creative ted-ed
animations check out this playlist and
if you want to help Ted ed continue to
work with artists like avi please
consider donating to our nonprofit
mission by visiting patreon.com slash
Ted ed
[Music]